il tente de jouer les médiateurs entre
moscou et kiev depuis le début de
l'invasion selon le wall street journal
l'oligarque roman abramovitch a souffert
de symptômes d'empoisonnement à la suite
d'une réunion dans la capitale
ukrainienne à la mi mars avec lui deux
autres responsables de l'équipe de
négociation de kiev aurait été touché
mais cette version interroge même du
côté ukrainien
[Musique]
nintendo a minima
baugé qui repose
non si l'histoire est chaud selon le
site d'investigation béline cat les
trois hommes ont consommé du chocolat et
de l'eau lors de la réunion quelques
heures plus tard il présente des yeux
rougis la peau de leurs visages et de
leurs mains se mettent à pelé d'après
les experts interrogés sur ce dossier le
dosage est le type de poison était
insuffisant pour mettre leur vie en
danger il aurait été probablement
utilisé pour faire peur aux victimes
selon le wall street journal les
soupçons se concentrent désormais sur la
ligne dure de moscou celle qui veut
saboter les pourparlers elle
souhaiterait rappelé à l'ordre le
propriétaire du club anglais de chelsea
jugé proche des occidentaux pourtant la
vente de son club a été suspendu par la
grande bretagne et l'union européenne
l'a inclus dans la liste des oligarques
faisant l'objet de sanctions washington
en revanche ne l'a pas sanctionné en
récompense de son rôle dans la recherche
de la paix malgré cet épisode il
continue aujourd'hui d'être actif dans
les négociations